what's up fol Podcast welcome everybody
to the W so Fu podcast with Filipe
sparza and guest hosting this week
Dustin bar what's up fool the Hair Club
of America is back baby oh man yeah
right Rodrigo Torres couldn't be here
because he's in sakas Mexico enjoying a
two wee vacation with his family who
live in sakas and um yeah so he's over
there hanging out you know eating eating
vegan tacos buying wrestling masks
buying fungus medicine for my toes over
there bringing back Calis it's cheap
over there [__] yeah do you got the
fungus man I got it I kind of like it
though dude I I'll get dude I'll be
scratching my feet and it feels so good
sometimes I'll tell my girlfriend like
you got to do this sometimes man I get
that little Ash like the little itch you
know you get like a little itch on your
body and it starts feeling good you go
nah man I ain't got [__] to do lat I'm
going to wait till I get home oh man n d
see you got self-discipline man I'll be
in the car in traffic and I'll pop off
one of my shoes like I can't wait I'll
just start scratching man it feels so
damn good or I'll get it under the gas
pedal where that little sharp corner is
and start going at it right there or me
like sometimes I'm I'm like at a meeting
or I'm doing something where I really
can't get up and go scratch and my
[__] butthole is itchy like a
[__] oh no it's like somebody
playing with it's like a a little [__]
is playing with a feather it's a demon
man that's isn't that some kind
of and I know that there's part there's
probably there's probably defecation
hanging out somewhere you know or I know
that once I scratch it's going to be
good oh yeah but you got to be careful
when you scratch your butthole out there
man you might scratch it so much you
might scratch that [__] into to
a hemorrhoid dude yeah you got to be
careful and they're over there like so
Felipe what do you think about this show
and all you're thinking is oh God no I
want a going to be good get a hot
napkin hot napkin Man Yeah man cuz you
know you want we a swelling down oh man
see sometimes man like I go like oh man
[__] should I eat first go scratch later
oh no I'm I'm one of those immediate
like you scratch right away if and start
itching wherever you're at I don't have
that self discipline I'm just one of
those guys yeah dude or I'll be like if
I'm like in somewhere where I can't let
people know I'm scratching I'll just
push my foot as hard as I can against
the bottom of my shoe and just rub it
back and forth ever so slightly and it's
not going to give you the full scratch
but it'll give you enough to get you to
the real scratch oh man like sometimes I
know like when I had when I when I used
to have real bad athletes feet it's
funny when they call it athletes feet
cuz most of the people who get it are
not athletes oh yeah
dude there was like one famous athlete
who got it 50 million other fat people
before them got it no credit there I
just tell you about how fat people get
athlet feed [__] don't take
their shoes off till night I know dud
what is with my God that was me though
dude that was me I didn't know I didn't
know how to do that man like cuz I I
know man when I was a little kid if I
took my shoes off that mean my dad say I
can't go back
outside that's hilarious so that was my
discipline in my head like if I [__]
leave my shoes off shoes on that means
I'm always look I'm always look I look
like a person is going to leave soon oh
man but if I leave a m if I take them
off my dad going to send me to bed early
or do something so it's still like
psychologically like in like the seed is
in your head like d i was a fat
[__] like even to like when I I
would not take my shoes off from 7:00 in
the morning till like 10: at night whoa
that's a lot of steam huh that is dude
and sometimes I can just feel it in
there just steaming up like oh man it's
going to be bad later it's going to be
really bad when you were hook up with a
chick and you didn't you weren't
expecting to hook up but your [__]
feet Stu dude that's happening what's
scarier is if they still go with it
you're like man what the this [__] is
crazy what does this [__] have yeah
exact if she's cool with my stinky feet
why is she like this doesn't make sense
I can either be like a super goodlook
guy without stinky feet or I got to look
like me and like you leave her alone
then you hear
this you're like you have a rabbit under
under the bed or what oh that's just me
scratching my crotch oh
no I never had that man oh man I'm the
way the one that's scratching man like
in that movie on planes TR automobiles
with Steve Martin and John Cy got to
sleep in the same room and it's taking
him forever to fall asleep then all of a
sudden he everything's quiet and all you
hear was
this the F scratching his balls for
about an hour
dog cuz men are disgusting animals man
what we do alone ladies if you knew what
we did alone you would never want to be
with a man for the rest of your life
it's pretty sick cuz we like to scratch
and sniff when we're alone that's how we
know it's time for a shower yeah and we
like to collect things too you know T it
like put in a little horrible like I
remember I was hanging out with the
other comic and we just decided bro
let's just wear the same shirt for two
week see what
happens what comic was this gabri GL
that's hilarious oh my God he's stiny we
[__] we're doing laundry at Lucy's
cuz that where all the comics go yeah
Lucy and um we're comparing underarm
stains yeah and that fool beat me bro he
had a [__] gray t-shirt a black
T-shirt and you can see the underarms
stain throw it dog it's like the
underarm stain with deodorant it would
just soak through I'm that [__] stung oh
man and that's the kind where even if it
dries you're still going to see the
stain in that like somehow the salt dep
matter what you got to put like double
of soap and then use fabric s softener
to get that smell away oh that is
horrible cuz I've done some laundry
before man and I smell and that [__]
still stinks like what the [__] am I
Arian what's going on oh man
dude sometimes if I don't unroll my
socks it'll do that you got to unroll
the socks flatten them out you can't
throw them in there like a bunch that's
what pisses me off man when you go out
and not do when your mom does not do
your [__] laundry it's
different my mom never came up to me in
my room yeah can you start unrolling
these [__] socks yeah exactly man my
mom never said come unroll these socks
she knew she has to unroll that [__] see
that's why I wanted to have a dad he
would have come and beat me been like
son these
socks said I got some mom who just lets
me get away with everything like I do my
laundry man and I always Rod my socks
because the [__]
stunk you can't just throw your socks
like that they [__] Ste man you got
to wrap them up in like a t-shirt and
some twim trunks yeah man like I don't
want my L my L's beautiful blouse to
smell like my socks oh yeah and because
you'll always see that too like each
time you see her in that blouse you're
like you're like oh man that that's a
athletes foot
B so what's fool Dustin iara right here
man you guys might have seen this guy on
everything because he's been on
everything once once right I'm like the
actually you been you on Batman Gotham
yeah Gotham did a couple episodes of
that and like uh Goldbergs Gotham was
the most fun though cuz I got to be all
serious and all tough guy in that all
crazy Arkham Asylum H did they get you a
spot on Comic Con no oh no oh man you
missed about an episode what if I just
showed up
that would be so lame though that'd be
like the dude like trying to get a gift
spot comic man you [__] show your own
booth oh my God and I'm in character in
costume too like man what's this guy
doing he needs to let it go I know man
he died after two episodes yeah come on
be cool but you were on for just two
episodes yeah you were part of um
Joker's crew right yeah we were called
they made it like into this big thing
called The Maniacs and uh it was like we
escaped out of Arkham and um then uh we
just rre havoc on the city and then
turned on each other slowly and
papy man when you have long hair like
like Dustin ioro and I you're always typ
cast as a crazy [__] yeah or the
guy that sleeps on the couch yeah the
stoner crazy guy yeah definitely
definitely not what we do in real life
whenever I got I had a network show and
they made me cut my hair a lot like it's
like I remember bro I couldn't tell you
a part from the other curly hair guy
okay yeah do you remember that I
remember a couple the Josh Gad dude a
couple of other people told me that too
and they were like dude what happened to
your hair cuz what they do is they try
to they want you to look networking and
all like ah family you know and like
really cute they they made me all like
cute version and it just look weird but
that was the best I ever looked I got to
say I you were clean cut I was clean cut
dude your your blue eyes showed more
exactly that's what when a studio is
behind you they can make you look good
and then I got to go back to pecoy man
I'm like oh God what was that I'm
calling my hairdresser what was that
stuff you put in my hair that made it
look not like [__] you ever walk around
man like when you're busy when when
things are happening or like the like
Barry cat says things are burning up um
man you were like like when when you
were on go right but you have to you
still have to go to pcoa and go do these
food even know oh that's how dude I've
never had that I think the closest I got
to that moment where like I think I've
made it was when I was shooting that
show in New York and then it got
cancelled before it even came out so
it's like I've learned like I don't know
you just I it Jimmy Walker told me that
he's like Dustin it's never one big
thing you're not just one day you're
just going to look around and say oh hey
here I am red carpet thing you know I
used to go on the road with him all the
time Jimmy Walker yeah dude yeah he was
the first dude that picked me up from
Dallas he's awesome man what was it like
working with Jimmy Walker how many times
did he say Dynamite privately to you
never ever I don't think till this day
Dynamite I think even I ask him like
Jimmy man can you do it once I don't
think he would man I don't think he
likes doing that no he has a big
following huh he does yeah and they're
really older now too I remember too
because it was really weird CU I was
like doing jokes about like Nintendo and
stupid you know stupid stuff and like
it's like all of his crowds are very
cruise ship and everything and I was
like wow this is a wild change but he
was awesome I love
Jimmy is this true that Jimmy Walker
doesn't like working with other black
comedians uh no he he actually yeah he
likes a lot of black Comics he just
doesn't like you got to be clean that's
the thing he tells you like uh you can't
say this you can't say that and I was a
cool with that I didn't like my favorite
Jimmy Walker joke was when he said that
um in he goes um it goes man we got
white people who won't even walk into
South Central won't even walk into the
ghettos of America but they're walking
into
Lebanon that's why would you go to
Lebanon man he goes on the passport they
write they they stamp it
hostage that's funny and then Jimmy
Walker had another joke he said that um
he said it's funny how in in Iran no in
in um Ireland in a country where there's
no blacks you got the Protestants
fighting the Catholics that goes to show
you man when there's no white those
black there's no blacks and Mexicans
living there white people know how to
improvise that's a dude I never heard
him do that that's hilarious oh my God
man I I switched the joke around you
know that's so
funny I switched the joke around homie
uh so you were on [__] uh Gotham the
show Gotham and you were on that movie
which I didn't see so we bought a zoo We
Bought a Zoo that's what they called it
too so we bought a zoo so you play the
Tasmanian devil in the movie right yeah
they you know they had I worked with a
good animal trainer he kept me in line
gave me my treats and everything but you
were in right was the the guy who did
the movie he the same guy who did that
movie um what's that movie Almost Famous
Almost Famous yeah Cameron Crow man he
was dude it was crazy that was my first
like little I saw you guys tweeting each
other on Twitter it was it was nuts man
see that's why I've had so many moments
I'm like this is awesome but his whole
like he's like he that was like the
first big thing I ever did and like he
was just so awesome like that that part
was so hard to get there was every I
remember seeing so many comics in that
room how did your roommates react to to
you getting this success while they were
coming back from a trial
run they were awesome man that was back
when we were all like yeah guys we're
goingon to make it we were all like we
all moved out together and it was
awesome and everyone we all helped each
other out I remember I mentioned I
didn't I didn't quite mention you guys
but I said yeah man like we're talking
about roommates you know it's always
tough when you have a roommate because
usually one is person is clean one is
dirty or one always has the red money
and the other one had a sad story every
month yeah it luckily our rent in pcoa
was so cheap there was no excuse for not
having rent money it was like 300 bucks
or something that's the best time bro
you got to move into the hood before
gentri vacation comes in dude I dude but
if you I used to do I have I told you
when when I do my special I said I used
to see white people coming in I will
walk around with no T-shirt in my
neighborhood just to scare them
bro and I'm the F and I'm the I I was
scared when I moved in there but after
why would you know other the homies bro
you realize man [__] they want you there
so I have my big apartment man I used to
do my own graffiti outside the
neighborhood I wanted my three bedroom
for 900 bucks a month to stay at 900
bucks a month oh yeah dude cuz it's done
after that man the thing is if you PL
you got to time it out perfect you know
what I'm saying the whole gation I time
it out perfect I went to I started off
at at Water M and that was before and
Cubans were still living there bro
Cubans and transvestites there were
Cubans in this part wow you have no idea
bro let me tell you man when the Cubans
showed up in 1970s in the Miami there
were so many there that um they said n
we got too many Miami too many Cubans
here so they started shipping um Cubans
to La this 1965 66 they showed up in
Echo Park and they had a big old [__]
Cuban community in um Echo Park that was
lost when mexin moved in but still but
but the Jose Marty he's the guy who
wrote One
he wrote he wrote that poem his [__]
statue is still there hipster is try to
try to move it bro it's going to still
stay there I don't give a [__] with the
white hipster say Jose Marty statue will
still stay there and they used to have a
big Cuban Festival in Echo Park now it's
the Lotus Festival it's for everybody
but still they used to be a Cuban
Festival I went to the last one by the
way and the biggest food line
was [__] papusas bro papusas that's
how you knew the Cuban Festival was
going down when when the biggest line
with papusas and vegan Jama um Jamaican
chicken turkey all right man we're going
to get to a shout out and then to our
guest cuz she's here waiting with her
beautiful dog all the way from East Los
Angeles
people what's up fol Dustin right here
co-host looking like Jee Puma son yep
drinking some Mountain Dew so man you
were in B We Bought a Zoo man you shot
that in Canada though no we shot that
here in um Thousand Oaks we shot it it
was like in this really nice
neighborhood it was
like that was like the richest area I
ever seen in my life dude really yeah
it's like that Hidden Valley area man
where it's just like it's just beautiful
that's what they make ranch the huge
yeah yeah they got all this stuff over
there man it's
crazy all right F we're going to get to
these put on me glasses unless you want
to do these shout
outs shout outs to Beth rocks she gave
us a nice review on iTunes and listens
listen to all 106 episodes in three
weeks to catch up glad you like the show
thanks for listening some people Bene
walk orange the new black and go through
13 episode some people just go to our
what food podcast and go to 106 episodes
that's awesome I'm glad that they let
you know too you know what I'm saying
cuz that sucks you you're like what's
going on and then bam I'm glad too man
because hey man you think I'm doing this
for good looks yeah
man Victor nto also in English that's
some Victor nephew or grandson oh Victor
nto also left with an iTunes review he
used to be in Silver Lake in LA and now
he's in Salt Lake City Utah He's a [__]
he wanted to have two wives I'll be back
in Salt Lake in August at Wise Guys Wise
Guys Comedy Club bro Wise Guys Comedy
Club I was there with Chris Thoren and
it's like I guess it's all ages it's
like you know I people who come to my
show are from the hood bro there was a
girl there at my show with her baby what
hell yeah man did you let her stay or
were you like no the baby was right
there on a on a little on a little
carrier sleeping oh laughing bro that's
awesome the dream she didn't let it hold
her back you know that's awesome she was
with a bunch of friends she said [__]
that this the only n they're going to
watch my baby I'm going to watch
Comedy I hate when Mom pull that [__]
man like when I have a when I had when I
had kids you try to go have first of all
first of you're a single mom single
parent don't ever in your life call your
mom and dad and ask them on the phone if
they can watch your kids [__] that you
show up with your kids and while they're
eating you [__] moon walk out of that
house oh that's a good idea
man that's how you do it bro I left my
kids there for 11 hours you want to tell
me how to raise my son mom you try it
that's great cuz they're not going to
kick their grandkids out you know what
are you going to do and leave your cell
phone there too man oh that is see that
takes it to the next level got you got
to teach your mom you got to teach your
m mom always my mom always try to tell
stuff like no M you got to do this you
got to do that okay Mom you try it by
yourself also our guest today okay we go
we'll get to
that get to that all right man what's up
fool man our next our host Our Guest
today first of all I didn't know that
who she was but I seen her art because I
lived in Echo Park in
2004 no 2006 to 2009 right or 2010
2009 201 and I used to live in downtown
I LA right there on Whitmer in the hood
and I live in tell you about where I
follow I gentrification chases me
follows me I follow I get to before
gentri fire bro like I lived in um
downtown LA on first day in Maine before
there was no store I had to walk to
China I I had to walk to Little Tokyo to
buy alcohol or the liquor store on
Macy's you get there you get there right
before it change if someone could follow
you with a lot of money you know and
just like predict like this guy Felipe
when he goes somewhere I'm telling you
the white people show up man I always
bro I it's what you got to do bro you
got to find out cuz see before I got
there gays leave first gay people are
the ones that have the most balls to
walk into a hood like South Central
where we live you know like normal
people and then to them it's like o
we're moving into the it's like an
adventure adventure my God to of black
crack
baby that is so I will see her this art
with a this little cute little dolls
with the big eyelashes like Rainbow
Bright chicks with big eyelashes all
over the the neighborhood then I will
see some other stuff you know but this
one always stood out to me because you
know it was sexy you know and and of
course like most people say okay this
got to be some gay dude doing these cuz
they're too good you know oh yeah like
that's definitely yeah that guy yeah cuz
you know most graffiti artist you hear
are are men like the um Heaven Chaka who
was we try to get here who in my
neighborhood but um I started seeing it
more then I saw this then I saw it in
perses then I saw um Roxy a radio DJ
host which I know she has some of her
stuff and I said then then we had a ho
we had a guest here on the show and then
they comment on her page you should get
sand one on your on your profile on your
podcast and I said oh I know who this
person is I seen her art then another
person said we should have her then I
found out she from East Los Angeles then
I said it's on then I started stalking
her page like or normal people do nice
try to get more about her yeah I found
out that her mom's photo her mom's
painting was stolen from a restaurant so
I dug In Too Deep cuz I'm a nosy
[__] yeah
dude hell yeah I started noticing that a
lot of her a lot of her she does a lot
she has her own Studio you know and um a
lot of her her painting she just she
paints with [__] dope man boots on
you know little dope man boots the
little brown boots boots you know which
is all normal for an artist
look if you're a male artist and you're
painting with no shirt on and you're
under on oh man provocative yeah this gu
for real a man doing it but once the
chick starts doing it that's what
another hate oh you you are you going to
be naked is yeah look at her man shaking
that thing and and these are women
making these comments oh yeah it's never
a dude who's like I can't believe this
oh you go to then I started stalking the
people or making those comments [__]
[__] has no followers ah man that's the
best though when you see that you're
like who are you who are you me a madis
I want another [__] address oh man
you get mad right you want to tell the
girl show me your body girl talking [__]
show me your body yeah let's compare
yeah yeah so we have Sanda right here
sand one sand one here artist graffiti
artist to the hood how are you I'm great
I've been watching you guys wild out
right now with your wild hair it looks
pretty intense I'm glad I combed it
today or else I would have look like you
guys I hate combing my hair and I'm
known for [__] hating com to comb my
hair and I literally got like hair
stylist friends that call me and they're
like hey today we know you have an
interview we're coming through I'm like
don't I don't need you no [__] we're
coming through and they show up with
their brushes and their [__] blow
dryers and I'm like all right now you
got to sit there and take it as long as
I get away without brushing my hair I'm
happy today I didn't get away with it
though but I'm here thank you for having
me here that's a I didn't bring spr but
I'm here I'm glad you manag if you would
not done your hair you would have been
our little sister totally that's what I
was kind of wanting to see you I was
like when there some Mo take over the
podcast jeez what are we doing I bet you
get asked a lot what are you what am I
well I'm Mexican I'm Mexican watermalon
and I'm a girl and I got this crazy
super power that's uh painting and after
I started painting I discovered I had a
big mouth pie piece and I was able to
talk my way into places and Deals and
then I just realiz that was a whole
combo like wow I could talk I'm not ugly
I'm very crazy I'm very creative and I
could paint really big big walls and I
don't understand why God gave me this
freaking gift but I'mma run with it so
everything I do every single day is Art
so I'm an artist here in La I'm LA's
cutest girl
artist I love your art oh was showing it
to me cuz I I don't live like around but
I was like oh my God this is dope this
is so and it's Unique It's like got that
unique it's not like oh this is special
man that's cool it's cute you look at it
and you're like oh my wife just left me
but that's
cute oh [__] I just got her [__] a
guy but that's really cute though let me
go over real quick like I realized it
throughout my years it's been seven
years that I've been painting so you've
seen it you know I'm pretty sure you've
seen it but you just don't know now that
you know me you're going to be like oh
yeah but now you're aware of it so
people I've been a part of people's
lives for the past seven years you know
girls having a miscarriage driving by my
character forgets all about her [__]
girls you know just got pregnant baby
daddy left her sees my character oh my
God life is cute you know so like I've
been a part of so many girls Liv Now
That I'm Older all these girls are
coming out of the wws like sand you've
been in my life and I'm like what here's
an air
freshener yeah like a lot of girls like
my work and I'm like you like my work
like it's it's not just me alone in the
streets like people are noticing right
like God I got to come up with something
okay I'm going to come out with an air
freshener oh my God I'm going to come
out with a phone charger like people
want my stuff and they can't just cut
the wall and take it home cuz it's so
big what do we do what do we do so
pretty crazy it's pretty intense
everything you do is DIY right do it
yourself yeah like I sit there for a
long hours literally in my building uh
the landlord was trying to kick me out
he was like you know you stay here after
work hours it is a 24-hour building but
you're here till 3 34 5 in the morning
and there's people in your building and
I'm like come inside my my office so you
can see what I do and he's like wow what
is this what is this I'm like I stay
here talking to people overseas on Skype
hello sand I want to do air freshener 5
in and packaging cardboard and uh you
know like when you talk to people in
China there's you can't be like what's
up dog I want to do an air fresher you
know what I mean and then I want you to
like plug it in with the cherry smell I
bet you they would love that though like
oh yeah they wouldn't know what I'm
talking about they wouldn't understand
what I'm saying so when I talk to people
overseas it's got to be very slow very
very slow so the landord the landord of
my building was like I'm going to kick
you out you're here every single night
I'm like come and see what I do and he
was like whoa this is intense I'm like
yeah I do everything myself control
freak that's cool so um that's that's
from that's smart man because a lot a
lot of comedians you know who are
popular they're so lazy you saw merch
yeah dude but I was lazy for a long time
it took me a bit to start and it was so
stupid cuz then you start making money
you're like man I could been been making
money this whole time you idiot I know
man like as soon as
um as I I I started selling merch
immediately when I used to go on on tour
with fluffy we were like we don't know
Gabriel glas we don't know what to do
right we went to a photo booth one of
those little seers family photo booth
that they have like um they have at
Walmart or Kmart and the three comedians
we took a photo together and we had them
printed and we signed them all and we
were selling them at the end of the show
for $5 that's great great man because
people people begin to love you and
they're like yeah they want a piece of
you and they could hear you but it's
like how can I have him like I want to
have him and my art I was like oh my God
there's so many people like what do I do
what do I do a sticker here a sticker
was it enough I'm like oh my God what do
I do I usually just go home with a
people go party let's go I know you like
my
art whoa children there's children here
there's a little doggy he's three years
old he shouldn't be listening to little
doggy yeah I had a simar thing I went
with a buddy of mine and we just
happened to show up and we're like man
we don't have any t-shirts or anything
so we bought whoopy cushions and printed
our faces on and we're like hey guys you
can sit on our face after the show $5
that's a [__] good idea bro I'm going
write that one down be C man do condos
with your faith on the package see bam
don't be a [__]
face you get mad request though man cuz
man it's cuz you got to deal with a lot
of perverse probably s you know people
tell you Philipe SP I know this lady I
said could we could I just have your
shirt at the end of the show
wow and it's all sweaty bro yeah and you
know you're dirt you know if you washed
or not we were just talking about that
before you got here yeah we were that's
that's crazy this has been a little
stinky episode we just talking about the
before earlier like when I used to have
a roommate I didn't have a roommate but
we were doing laundry at Lucy's right
you know and um we were we we told we
made a we we had a contest let's see who
could wear the the same name shirt the
longest who won who won I lost of course
that's great you got decent these two
wear a great t-shirt you know we're
comparing underarm stains and hit a
underarm stain on a great t-shirt I said
you win dog I think you're conscious
there was your mom talking to
you I used speaking you're right I used
to get mad man when my mom would tell me
to go take a
bath M I used to hate that she could we
hot water would be
hey you wanted that that poop on your
butt crusting in there you were trying
to save as much as you could on your
body body weight in
there or when you get a girlfriend for
the first
time like whoa why can't I have a girl
with a little booty Dirty Man a little
booty I know man you didn't heard to
toss my salad I've heard of that I've
heard of that I've never had it happen
before me knew there only one time bro
felt like man this am I going to be gay
after
this but you're not though right I'm not
hell no hell no hell no but there was
that inkling of like oh man I really dig
this but not too much I know man they
they then like um cuz they don't really
talk about that stuff you know the men's
side of it like on only one on The
Sopranos The Sopranos the old man he
like oral sex on women like he like
doing it to women so then they started
talking about it they started talking
about it next thing you know he's gay
why I don't know like it's oh you're not
a man oh cuz he degrade himself to going
down know yeah yeah you know what I hate
that [__] when it's like hey give me
head or what's up you give me head oh
what the [__] what the [__] why why am I
going to why I'm I [__] with chopsticks
oh man yeah that's like one of my main
attributes I got to like this the best
that's going to get out of the whole
thing is it a comedian thing or what man
if I were a SIMS character that would be
my highest attribute like I would G the
most points to
[__] play the
trumpet larious so um how' you get
started like a lot of our list our
listeners here they they're hearing
about you for the first time right A lot
of them know who you are because a lot
of listeners are from Big La Big East
lws you're from East Los e Ela not dues
by the way East LA Atlantic and wter
Boulevard
Church oh [__] I know what that is and I
used to go to santoso church on the
summer and be right there all crammed up
I never learn how to
swim there was not that much space you
know with all the Mexicans farting next
to each other oh it's one of those where
everyone just goes there yeah you pay 25
when you get in the PO oh no no no I I
think back thinking back on my old days
and I'm like why the [__] can't I swim
but there's no room to swim in the hood
everybody's trying to soak in somewhere
and that sop phon a for you oh man it's
sad cuz I could just picture that pool
like shallow it's all yellow
from if I see like three people in the
pool I'm like this is too much I'm not
this everybody's peeing and haming and
your dirt is fing off oh and then that
little film above the water that little
icky like oh what is this stuff is it
like sweat is it like hair gel and then
there's people who are me who are darker
skin were oilier
bro
Li dark ass M bro I have acne on my back
not now but before and you're walking
through the
pool popping everyone's pimp everyone's
pimpled that you around your shoulder
hey Dustin sand I was that mexan foood
that you look when it jumped in the
water and I jump out hey he don't even
look
wet I drive by Santa fonso church now I
mean I'm from E La I'm from E LA right
and and I still live in East I just went
back but when I moved to downtown I was
living at this place called The
Watermark and the pool was so beautiful
everything was so beautiful and the
people were so beautiful I'm like what
the [__] like over there you the Pancho
Tana you know what I mean like they're
all different sizes and you go to the
water mark and everyone's beautiful and
you got to suck it in like you know what
I mean it was a culture Clash there's no
like Bud Light can floating around the I
know champagne baby champagne and caviar
but yeah I'm from E I started painting
seven years ago when I was 17 and I just
been running with my art ever since like
I just felt like I need to do something
crazy and I used to play soccer but
nobody [__] noticed me when I used to
play soccer cuz I suck balls but there
was a girl named Lily that everybody
would be like yeah Lily oh you scored a
goal and I'll be like I need to be Lily
so now I'm Lily but through ART yeah but
what's Lily doing now I don't know she's
probably
pregnant with a baby daddy issues she
probably like she she probably bended
Like
Beckham I don't know where L probably
bend over like Beckham all right people
week but I used to sit there like after
like we were done playing soccer and
chasing a ball for an hour and a half
cuz I was middle right and I used to be
like damn Lily again I gave her the ball
though like if it wasn't because of me
she wouldn't but whatever Lily get the
credit so now that I'm older and I'm
this artist like I do art shows and
girls come it's like when you like
people come and they like oh I love you
give me your shirt you know let me rub
your gut you know like let me rub
your let me try to rub my fingers
through your tangled hair how did she
know that rut let me
think oh man I had people tell me they
you want to rub your gut they just want
to do that
man they make you all conscious my God I
don't want to do that come on man that's
what sucks after to show like please
don't rub my
belly wellow I like people rubbing my
belly too but I became an artist and
then I started noticing people noticing
me like they used to notice L when I
used to play soccer and I was like this
is it this is where I belong I belong
I belong in this world and then I
started building my own world like when
I started painting I was like okay who
am I painting for am I painting to get
other artist to be like yeah F high five
you're just dope I'm an artist too or am
I painting to speak to like the people
the people the normal girl that works a
925 at McDonald's is going to go home
and give titty to her baby or the girl
that works at at a nursing uh office and
she does medical billing but she's
watching my Instagram and she's like oh
I wish I could paint that big doll like
who am I painting for like am I painting
for the girl the mom's a regular girl or
am I painting for other artists I was
like I'm going to paint for women and
that's what I CH that's what I've been
running with yeah like I just I just
when I paint a girl I'm like is this
girl G to like this though hold on too
much boob let me take out the boob hold
on let me put a turtleneck on her for
all the conservative people like you
know like I think about women when I
paint stuff oh girls wear glasses let me
put some glasses on her with tape around
the little middle cuz she can't afford
to buy new glasses cuz the medic would
just went off you ever you ever think of
just like painting like the McDonald's
crew like Ronald McDonald and like all
of his crew and then trying to sell it
to McDonald's for money I do think you
know what I did Bessie Johnson I painted
a painting for Bessy Johnson it took me
a year to get it to her but I got it to
her and now she has it in her uh
granddaughter's uh bedroom so it's the
same idea yeah we try to get yeah be
like painting things for people be like
look what I made you but it's going to
cost you some money make sure you tag me
on
Instagram what I like what she said that
um am I going to be a painter for other
painters and other artists who say oh
yeah man you're I'm a p you're a pter oh
man that [__] get old after a while man
like um for other people like my my
comedian for other comedians you know oh
yeah yeah cuz there's a a lot a lot of
that stuff goes on how like you see you
go to an art show and there the same
artist all the time supporting each
other I'm not going to pick no say no
names but hey man could you start
painting chapolin so many times how many
times you going to paint champoline yeah
we got enough chapolin bro yeah yeah but
all the other artists really like it so
yeah but don't know but my blue Dem one
is wearing a dress but honestly artists
don't really buy from each other you
know like cuz I'm an artist I have so
many paintings I don't want to buy from
the other artist but I'll go support his
[__] but I don't want to buy his
painting cuz where am I going to stuff
it at when I got like a thousand
painting stuffed right here you know
what I mean I'll put it all the way in
the back maybe and just know that I
support him so like I was like I want
women so like now when I do an art show
like hundreds of women come and I'm like
and they don't know anything about art
and they don't have to know anything
it's like maybe the people that come to
you they don't know sh about the first
comedian that started the generation and
the open that opened the doors to the
world of Comedy like they don't have to
know they love you and they love what
comes out of your mouth and they love
your your your your the funny [__] that
you say and that's pretty much what I've
what I've made my art be I was like I
want this art to appeal to women and
little kids and men for them to be like
oh like I literally say relationship
this guy he's the main hit something
manager director for Lamborghini right
in like Venice Beach he messages me he
said my girlfriend just left me because
I've been cheating on her so many times
I'm like whoa he's said please call me
pleas here's my number I want to buy a
painting I'm like bro I'm not calling
unless I know it's serious I'm going to
send you an invo before I even call you
because I want to make sure that you're
not just trying to get on the phone and
hear my voice right ow that hurt I
almost broke the iPhone I forgot I had
the earphones and the guy and then you
know I get an email by this girl and
she's like I just broke up with my guy
you know and I have a new boyfriend he
has a coffee shop and I was driving to
the coffee shop in Hollywood and I saw
one of your dolls but when we used to
live in Venice I used to see I'm like
whoa what is this triangle so then I
called the guy and he's like did a girl
named Nicole message you I'm like yeah
and then I'm like yeah she says I was
driving to my boyfriend's coffee shop
and he's like oh that's her new
boyfriend I'm like whoa whoa are you
going to buy this painting before I keep
reading the email that she sent me so
the guy paid for the painting but I was
like I'm going to love tryangle right
now you better buy this [__] painting
the guyy like I love her and I need to
get her back I'm like bro now you need
to be the alpha male you know making
sure you bought the painting oh yeah I'm
like now you need to attack and apply
pressure you messed up buy the painting
that's going to make her want to and
he's like all right fan in fact you
might need two paintings yeah yeah you
know what I'm going to give you three
paintings for 10,000 and she going to AR
you yeah she's going to be all up on
your nuts after that no problem just uh
send me the check and uh I'll start my
uh Doodles you know I'll go to Michael's
right now and buy our supplies for you
but yeah that's crazy all I know if I
had a Lamborghini dealership I wouldn't
be tripping too much you know hey he
must love her a lot though like that
that must be the one from all the
strippery he cheated on like that must
be the one you know she's the one that
makes his little thingy tingle her name
probably is Lamborghini too that's
what's crazy about it he loves her dude
he loves her like I be I like I people
have proposed in front of my paintings
like one time this guy proposed and the
painting is alha Alvarado by like
MacArthur Park and the guy he never told
me he was a cop until like recently I
walked into a coffee shop and there was
like three cops and they're like oh you
painted a mural for one of our comrades
and I'm like what and they're like yeah
the guy with the penguin mural and I'm
like oh he was a c and I was in I was in
my car showing him like oh you could
pick that wall right there with no
license like you could pick that wall
right there like he didn't tell me he
was a cop he knew I would freak out and
not take the deal so he pays me to paint
a mural because his girlfriend is so
psycho about me his girlfriend takes
photos of all my murals in LA and she
knows every location so he's like she
always drives by here Alvarado and uh
8th Street I'm like cool then let's do
it right here I have that wall available
the next morning like the next week I
wake up and I'm freaking out I'm like
comeb your hair look good I'm like it's
not my day it's his day so they're
supposed to be walking by and all of a
sudden they walk by and I'm doing a
mural so they walk across the street and
I'm like oh [__] play your positions all
my friends are acting like they're
painting or I'm playing stupid and then
I turned around and I and I covered the
part where it saids Patty Gomez will you
marry me so I'm like oh [__] like I'm a
part of somebody's New Beginning this is
serious um and then they walk up and
then he's like he stares at me and I
look at him and I just doged him you
know eell style
like and I'm right there on the LA her
and I was like all right what do I do
what do I do they're staring at me and I
looked at her I'm like hey do me a favor
yeah remove that big ass paper from the
wall she's like okay I'm giving attitude
like I don't want to be sweet to her and
I I look I gave I I gave my home girl
the thing and I was like hey are we done
already and they're like yeah we're done
the girl remov the paper and says Patty
go will you marry me she starts crying
and she runs up to me hugs me she's like
I love you s the guy's on his knees with
the ring I'm like hey girlfriend your
man's right there and then she turns
around they got married but it was
pretty intense I was like oh [__] this
mural is a beginning to them and I done
waiting murals and paintings and I'm
like damn they want they want me to be a
part of their life like this is serious
like I'm bringing them together I'm like
the priest you know hell yeah man that's
awesome it's like if you marry someone
have you married someone on stage yet
you should I'm surprised no one's asking
that I've had people propose to each
other at my show and then later on they
tell me they proposed at my show oh but
they didn't make a big like Felipe no
you're like man I'm telling my jokes I I
had a I had I had some some I hope he's
not listening I some stupid guy um he he
Instagram he's probably listening he
said um hey man can you give um me and
my lady a shout out we've been together
four years and she's going to have a
baby no no no he he hadn't said he L he
hadn't he hadn't told her he loved her
but they've been together four years or
two years they had a baby and they had a
baby oh he never said so went up on
stage and I said man there's a guy here
that want to tell his lady that he loves
her for the first time what little be
where you at and he's right there wait
wait wait wait wait you man your
girlfriend's pregnant and you have a
baby you still haven't told her you love
her leave this [__] wow why
can't he just say it I know what kind of
tough guy I know man leave this guy I on
the stage I don't understand how dudes
can do that I'm one of those guys
there's no big deal to me I'll be like I
love you I love you I tell every like
girl love you you're like a gr me yeah
yeah it's like you're like hot you're
like Hot Pockets to me I love you I like
Pockets exactly I love Hot Pockets I
love everything I'm a lovable I like
things man we're lovers we're lovers he
was probably like a emotional
emotionally detached yeah but even if
like bro she's two kids in you better
love her I know but my dad never hugged
me okay God come on I remember some girl
told me I love you and I said that's
cool oh that's staying you I know I got
I got gu that be like hey what's up S
you know I want a relationship I'm like
for what what are we going to do in a
relationship like I think we already are
we take each other every single day or I
got guys that go in there like hey S I
follow you on Instagram what the [__]
are you doing on my Instagram like
you're supposed to only come through at
night like what are you doing on my
Instagram well I don't know I'm like dud
you got my direct line get the [__] off
my Instagram you know I saw your video
that you posted about booty cough I'm
like get the [__] out of here with that
I'm like look do not believe social
media it's all fake like I I don't
really think like that but I do
I'm like you need to get off my social
media you know like on social media I
get wild and I talk about like you know
Screw love and put your feelings in a
box I kind of mean it but I don't hey S
I I I I liked your page and unliked it
two times just so you could notice me oh
[__] you're being a psycho you're being
a psychopath right now I know people do
that dude I've accidentally done that to
someone and felt like a psycho I I had
to call them up and be like hey dude
sorry forgot I actually put unfollow and
I clicked it and then I put follow right
afterwards so I'm sure you made it I got
this i got this guy that tells me like
you don't if I like your photo yesterday
no [__] I didn't notice you like my
photo what's up what are you doing you
want to kick it you want to go out
somewhere like what are we doing right
now why are you liking my photos oh yeah
that's how you feel on Instagram no one
time I got a phone call and this guy was
like you're lying you said you were
going to be in Vegas I'm
like do you follow me on Snapchat no I'm
like unfollow me what is your name I'm
blocking you what are you doing on my
Snapchat if I say I'm in Vegas I'm in
Vegas what's your
Pinterest yeah that's you know it's like
hey what's Tumblr you got a LinkedIn who
if you block up everywhere they'll find
you on y hey man you're eating that
too hey you're on back page too like me
no way that's crazy I put an that on
Craigslist the other day hey I saw your
business card and that massage piler oh
man I found your number somewhere
a pigeon just shows up with a little
note like what the hell is it or you you
do a or sometimes like you always know
who the real perverts are the real
perverts will always tell you right away
straight up they don't hold back oh man
you're a big ass straight up they go for
the obvious they do they go for the
obvious those are the real kill it but
then the undercover perverts you do your
thing girl oh oh I want a painting how
much is the painting oh uh 750 for the
little mini one 2500 oh yeah so so can
we go out home hold up you like my art
or you like my ass what's up with it
brother [__] you look at you you're so
shallow you're what do you mean you
asking for a painting you initiated the
conversation with business then just
initiate it straight to where you're
going it was so UPS you're cute black
you're not
cute that's crazy you know what the the
the the most sensitive ego is a man's
ego yeah I don't know maybe you get
you're
different by you saying that I put
myself in that guy's position and was
like man my feelings are HT right now oh
she's a bit she's so mean she's not even
that fine why are you bothering me in
the first place yeah oh she she rejected
me she's not even that cute but we went
nowaday you Tred to sell me a painting
afterwards now he's feeling all the yeah
yeah one guy was like hey I have a
graffiti store you want to paint it I'm
like no I'm straight oh see that's why
no one likes you brother oh man what's
up brother I
don't yeah whatever it's like what's
your problem [__] come on I'm offering
you some free wall right here I don't
want it thank you very much there's
other people that need it oh you're a
[__] okay okay okay okay well yeah I'm
sorry I I just don't feel like driving
there listen if you're not going to go
out of the date with me after I
literally gave you some help kind of
there was a guy that was like Hey you
know I have a bunch of trailers I want
you to paint them all I'm like cool here
the invoice for each one still I think
hear the invoice but he's telling me all
these things I'm like BR brother you
know when I say brother that means that
you're my brother like that's me putting
you on the hold line the D goes crazy
he's like you know what you have an
enemy now this is this is this gang from
this gang and these are my I'm like who
just because I was like listen I've I've
entertained this conversation for
already a week are you going to pay the
invoices or not let me know if you're
serious about doing business because you
keep coming at me you know in a non-
business Manner and I feel very
uncomfortable boom he blew up started
gang banging on me Instagram gang
banging on in
dc99 you know what's crazy I have a lot
of friends cuz when I first moved out
here I lived in boa and I moved in with
a gang banger yeah yeah they uh the dude
dude just been shot and he got out of
the gang you know cuz you know once you
get shot it's he's like I think I
learned my lesson here theable list but
they'll be like I'll like see [__] pop
up on my Facebook sometimes just these
little fights between like hey P now
I'll be in San Fernando what' you say
about San Fernando San Fernando and then
they'll start gang bang back and forth
and I'm like guys listen I'm at the ice
house this
Saturday we didn't go to along with
Pasadena hey me at the meet at the ice
house put your guns away for a bit until
I I'm done with my show tell me when
there's a PMA Comedy Club a
man I don't know but you guess you're
pretty funny so what happened um I know
getting back to me being nosy on your
page oh let's talk about it let's talk
about it what happened um to your mom's
painting how did that come about did you
get it back I I heard check back on your
page andiana I got the painting back but
it was a crazy seven-year thing that
happened so I'm seven you stole your
painting yeah so I did a painting and it
was uh three paintings for the Chinese
American Museum in Downtown LA the first
time I ever I ever Showcase in the
museum also that's a big deal I felt H
like why why her yeah why her she ain't
even that good when I must be that good
if I'm in there and you're not get your
bars up you know like it doesn't come
through luck like you being here sitting
down in front of that mic both of you
guys it's not luck you wake up every
single day you're like okay whose door
do I knock on who freaking window do I
crack like you know what I mean like who
I got to sleep with now yeah jeez think
I got
toan what comedian do I got to give a
right to the airport for this I know I
need connections man let me let me hop
out his grandma real quick and get
through him I follow her on
Instagram little let me get through the
little brother so uh seven years ago I'm
doing this painting I've always been
good at painting ever since I started I
just knew what to do with the brush and
the acrylic paint I knew what to do so
like it's my first year into art and the
museum hits me up mind you I'm next to a
bunch of like wellknown established
artist and I'm like whoa I'm rolling
with the big dogs right now little dog
big dog I'm a big dog now so I do the
painting and I do one that was my mom it
was supposed to be like a like Mexican
culture uh Art Exhibit so I do my mom in
her lunch truck holding like a taco
plate with her hat with her little name
tag with her name there's got aada in
the back my stepdad with like a $100
bill cuz he would always go try to like
pick up on her and be like hey let me
get 10 tacos here's a 100 bucks she
thought he was a freaking baller he was
Broker Than I was when I was
16 but he he pretty much will give her
his whole half of his freaking paycheck
okay by giving her that money so she f
for you know little little shallow lady
right there oh $100 and it's only $10 so
they get pregnant whatever so I do the
painting and it goes on the on the Art
Exhibit then it comes down from the
museum and there's another art show
going on in this Gallery in downtown the
owner hits me up tells me to put my art
in there I put it up but that one was
not for sale cuz it was my mom that's
the only painting that I've ever had
sentimental value torch for so long next
thing you know the r show ends and the
guy the owner of the gallery he was this
like french guy very standoffish french
guy Tony he's like sorry your painting
was stolen and uh there's nothing I can
do I'm like what what do you mean he's
like is stolen stolen so what do I do
now nothing you can do I spoke to
insurance company and they say nothing
you can do I'm 17 I have no idea what's
going on I'm scared I'm broke so I don't
even want to fight I can't even call my
homies from like you know the mavia gang
like hey what's up homies you know we
got to roll out and like pull up on all
these freaking Gallery owners like I
don't want to say nothing fo yeah I want
a mon come on I was like Sam what do you
do like okay you know what just walk
away
just walk away so I walk away and for 7
years that always haunted me like where
is that painting like who stole it who
would just walk into a gallery and steal
it right seven years later I get
something on Snapchat and this girl's
like hey s I'm eating in front of your
painting the one that you said got stole
at your mom's painting I'm Mia's
house and and I was like that's my mom's
painting I'm like where are you shut and
she's like I'm at beep fish that's the
restaurant right beat fish and I was
like I Googled it and they have three
locations so I go to the one next to me
in downtown I walk in and there's my
mom's painting sitting there on the
counter not even hanging up like it
should sitting there on the counter and
I'm like okay think quick think quick
think quick I'm like oh the Mexican
workers hola I can't to pick up the
painting it's my painting I'm trying to
be civilized you know what I mean I
would have done that here's the
key to me I think the key to this
business to our industry you don't ask
you demand I want a radio show you know
what I mean and you got it you know
Felipe so I walked in there and I'm like
I'm here to pick up the
painting and they're like no I'm like
damn it oh they're like we're calling
the boss that's Lo no no no and I'm like
damn it so they call the boss and I get
on the on the phone with the boss he's
like no that's my painting I'm like look
it's stolen somebody stole it from me
I'm gonna take it he's like get out of
my permit before I call the cop then I'm
like
why I'm calling the cops then so I'm
like damn and then I call my homies and
they're like ay sound we'll write out
right now we'll take that painting I'm
like yeah but then that means we're
stealing from a freaking location I'm
like oh I'm like you know what I'm just
going to be legit civilized American and
I'm going to call the cop I call the cop
the cops get there 30 minutes later I'm
outside waiting by that time I'm on
Snapchat and Instagram rolling I'm right
here my painting stolen Blah Blah Blah
by then all my fans are rolling through
calling the restaurant like you better
give her her painting back they they're
calling ordering food not paying so it's
already they doing a typical prank like
hey let me get Tas and there's nobody to
pick up the T mean I'm at home going who
what what's going on what yeah yeah so
30 minutes later the cops come I walk in
there and they're like where's the
painting there's no painting in there
they took it so I'm furious and I pull
out my phone and I'm like look 345 I
took a photo the painting was right
there 320 I took a screenshot of the
person they're like okay search warrant
come back they find the painting they
pull it out they're like go to the
police station and show us proof that
it's your painting I'm like cool I go to
my office pull out the paintings bring
them back they're like sorry we can't
give it to you I'm like what they're
like we left it at the at the restaurant
because we don't know if if if it's
really stolen so then a whole ordeal
starts going on their Instagram gets
shut down their freaking Y is booming
and is falling down on stars all the way
to like half of like the orangey one
yellow one the lowest you could get if
you have like an F quality restaurant uh
it's crazy now there's lawyers involved
they send me a lawyer and they call my
lawyer and and now we have that I don't
have I don't even have a lawyer I have
an assistant you know but she's being
the mediator and then they get on the
phone with me and they're like you know
little girl you've got a lot of trouble
in our business I'm like I just want my
painting back so now we're doing some
gangster [__] where we're like trying to
negotiate and there's Eagles in the way
and then finally in the midst of
everything this Middle Eastern girl
comes into place and she's like my
friend I am a lawyer and I love your
work I am going to be your lawyer I'm
like what do you want she's like
painting I'm like done deal nice so now
I got Nas Nas M and she's rolling in
there all Lo out I already want to give
her my and she was a real a real lawyer
I was like are you a real lawyer though
I'm trying to get a painting from me she
was a real lawyer and boom I get the
painting back after two months of going
at it we're just going at it dude and
they don't want to they don't want to
give they don't want to bow down I don't
want to bow down you know we got we're
Mexican we got Pride it's like hey just
give it back no come on dog no I got a
lawyer then and then that's when it got
intense and their lawyer was pregnant so
she like just dropped the ball like f
there just take the page she didn't even
care she like I have this [__] baby I
can't deal with this but in the end we
got it and now were best friends and we
got drunk together that day and we just
got all wasted and I woke up in my
freaking living room my painting next to
me my assistant like you got wasted s
you were so happy about the painting I'm
like I don't even get wasted
man just that luck if it was me they
would have I would have never gotten
that painting they would have putting a
mustache on it like here's your stupid
painting Dustin I made I made drama with
that that is so awesome it was wild oh
yeah cuz I remember um you also had um
you you I remember you were reading
something like this about the the court
paper and it remind me of Lenny Bruce
the comedian Lenny Bruce remember Lenny
Bruce was going through that um Court
thing to fight for his rights as a as a
comedian he said like saying he said
[__] he said [__] and he said um that
that the owner called these gay guys
[__] so he couldn't say that on stage so
you were reading it and I remember you
reading the same thing things about
these [__] [__] till they we my
painting then you put a I remember I sh
I liked that the you put like my my mom
painting and my underwear too okay that
was when the drama I'm 70,000 likes I
was like if you guys want me if you guys
want me to say sorry I'm not sorry
because this is the so in the in the end
the owner of the gallery lied to me and
told me it was stolen it was never
stolen he lied on me to give it to his
girlfriend at the time that was from E
so he me your painties always bring
relationships together though yeah yeah
okay okay okay so but but he cheated on
her and left her and now he's engaged to
this girl which I know because I emailed
him like what's up Tony you need to say
something you need to give me my
painting back because you are the cause
of all this [__] whatever my fans are
doing all this drama you are the
freaking source of this because you told
me it was stolen it was never stolen oh
you know I forgot and I found it no you
don't find a freaking 40 by 60 painting
all of a sudden and not know like that
you need you need a truck to haul that
painting yeah it wasn't an iPhone sh
yeah it was a big ass painting do it was
a little air fresh I found the air fresh
and just give it to you know to you no
that was that was real [__] so they're
like you got to say sorry and I'm like
sorry for what I was lied to you know so
he leted to me gave it to his girlfriend
and then he left her so that's all she
has to hold on to to now and her mom
died so that painting reminds her of her
mom but that's my mom selling tacos
whole crazy thing so then when they tell
me to say sorry I'm like fine I'm going
to clear the restaurant from all this
mess because they were just displaying
it but if I'm going to go out I am not
going to go down like a bee I'm going to
go all like a g so I bought a bathing
suit in downtown for five bucks and I
put I want my painting and then I
grabbed papers because I I'm going
forget my speech so I wrote my speech on
the papers and it went something like
this like you know so according to the
whole drama the guy told me that it was
stolen but now his girl is going to get
married to him and he cheated on the
girl that now owns the painting so that
heated the people the restaurant and the
girl that was having the painting they
were so angry they're like she's so
arrogant why can't she just say sorry
I'm not going to say sorry because I am
not sorry this is a mess so n didn't
want to give it to me because I didn't
say sorry and then the day we agreed to
meet I left to Mexico cuz I was like I
need to go to the pyramid and get
enlightened so I go to the pyramid then
I'm in the pyramid freaking the sun
pyramid cuz the the smallest one in
Mexico if you go if you go to the Moon
one it's a mission or maybe it's the
moon one I don't know it's really big I
can't do that I can't go all the way to
the top I got to the middle of the
pyramid I was like if the if the atics
got to the middle and got energy I'm
going to just stay right here I'm not
going to go all the way up there that's
where they lose their oh yeah man that's
why I don't sit that's why I don't like
walking those stairs to the upper deck
of DOD Stadium bro oh you feel like
you're going to get sacrific like after
Apocalypto keep it l it low there some
dude up there just waiting my head's
going to roll down so kids going to pick
it up so I I go I go to the pyramid and
then they call my lawyer and they're
like she's in Mexico if we meet for the
painting we got to meet with her in
person so I was like damn now they
became
fans it's crazy so then we meet up and
we get the painting but it was crazy and
then I was mad cuz I didn't get the
painting so when I came back that's when
I did that thing on the wall and I was
like I'mma put my underwear on and it's
pretty much like kiss my ass [__]
like I want my painting back that was
the first time I ever done a video where
I'm my underwear my butt cheeks hanging
out I was like but it's not really like
sexual it's more like a statement you
know cuz I'm an artist Hollywood loves
me for that whenever I get naked oh yeah
this is a statement titties guy just
titties that's all that's all my
contract says they me more specifically
it says only titties Dustin they pay me
to keep clothes on it's in you're kind
like Felipe listen we will give you an
extra 20 grand if you just don't e
Felipe can you start switching to um X
double X I saw your stretch marks in Fr
row I can see no he doesn't have stretch
mics actually wow what do you put she
have
butter like Coco butter all that [__]
doesn't work by the way vitamin E
doesn't work it thanks for you know what
works putting on extra shirt under belly
yeah you just got to put on an
undershirt I hate that when I'm on stage
and I lift up my arm to do something and
I'll get a laugh and I'll be like that
wasn't even and I'll be like oh my belly
just showed that's why everyone was like
your belly showing it wasn't his joke no
ever growing up my mom like I I'll cut
myself or something water with salt
water with salt I'm [__] dying mom
told I'm dying told you I'm dying right
here and you're putting water with salt
got I told my wife that I said no one
time when I cut a big ass cut on my knee
my mom I swear to God put salt on it and
she said I can't believe she put salt no
she [__] put salt does that work no
that I was going to say that's like you
got to go to the doctor and be an actual
American and just get that [__] thrown
Stop Believing in the guy in the the
grace of God to cure you like literally
I spent a whole week where I couldn't
eat cuz it hurt so much I had like my
throat
like right I tequila shot with lemon and
honey oh water and salt all these
Mexican things not even real Salt like
the McDonald's I finally got tired of
that [__] a hot Sprite oh yeah yeah yeah
with with with all this [__] right oh
pray to God pray to God dude I finally
go to the doctor paid 0 bucks got a shot
on my ass 30 minutes later all my pain
was gone I'm like I hate Mexican
remedies oh put baked
paper starts rubbing you with an egg
like get
away they didn't work but for our one
listener out there who's been asking
about hemorrhoids putting Vapor Rub does
work you got to sit on a pillow at
Circle you got to sit on a circle pillow
too so your hemorrhoids like fall nicely
you know in the middle of it when you're
driving I just lay on my stomach all day
it's going to be a stomach day for dust
you know asses up stomach down watch
little Bachelorette I like I like her
idea better the donut the donut donut
thing I'm trying to make an invention
bro where I could just get that that
Circle heated pad get heat it bro oh get
some heat on it then really put your
face in it and F it I feel like that
would mess with the they'll buy that
[__] after after your comedy show I just
came out with the round donut heated P
you can sit it on my face ladies you
know once you buy one of those though
you're going to have that forever you
know what I'm saying like you kind of
expect like I'm probably gonna have
another I'm actually promoting the
Filipe sparza squatty potties oh what is
that I don't know yeah I i' seen those
man I have one of those you do it works
are you serious it works man I do the GU
what it called s a Squatty Potty it's a
thing it's a it's a stool that you put
around your toilet and your legs rise up
and you sit down so so you you're
actually [__] like a Chinese guy
normal it's the way supposed to poop
really they said that's how caveman did
it I think yeah cuz you you're sitting
like your legs up it's a Squatty Potty
you put your knees you put your legs on
it then you sit down the toilet and then
so you're like elevated yeah you can
even just use a couple of telephone it
makes the poop comes down smoother it
keep going down instead of going like to
the side yeah do you even have to wipe
your ass afterwards dude nothing that I
didn't lie that only happened to me in
my lifetime twice where you have to wipe
uh when you were to Japan
maybe I went to Japan and literally for
the whole two month I was there I never
had to touch my butt I I would just sit
there yeah like the first time it
happened I was
like tickles because it was it's weird
it's like w is somebody back there you
know me I was like and then I got used
to it but the first time I at the
airport and everybody like I was
literally Snapchatting like and then I
come out and everybody just staring at
me and I was like oh [__] to them it's
normal but to me it's not normal it
washes your butt like literally it's hot
water and it just squirts into your ass
and it just removes all the little
particles and then it dries it up it
dries it too yeah and [__] the little
machine moves to the front so it can
wash your the JJ and then it moves to
the back oh with balls too they'll just
that looks so weird just air pressure
under balls no more ball juice no more
no one balls will never smell like a
like a catcher's M ever again you are so
so clean in Japan like I went over there
to go paint and it was crazy cuz I took
a luggage full of pillows and
merchandise I only saw like three
pillows and I was like what they're not
into like street art they're not in they
weren't into my art and I took a huge
gamble I went over there with a little
backpack full of little thin clothes
wearing the same pants for like a week
and a big ass big ass like army bag full
of merchandise and I only sold three
pillows and the rest I just gave it away
like here you go oh you own a company
call me here this bodu put it on let me
know when you want to work with me like
like trying to collab like that was like
my marketing like [__] business card
and I was like wow like I didn't sell
[__] but I paint I painted a couple of
walls in Japan and then I hopped on to
Thailand and painted a bunch of walls in
Thailand and then I hit up the
newspapers in Thailand just balls out
just demand I hit up all the newspapers
and one newspaper answer the biggest one
in there it's like the LA weekly and
they were like we'll do a story on you
I'm in Thailand for 3 weeks eating
freaking Thai food and watching horse
make money and I'm not making no money
I'm just spending it so I'm like you
know I'm kind of considering my life
right
now for like five bucks you can get you
can get it all night baby for five bucks
it was crazy cheap Thai food and bomb
women oh man for five bucks five bucks
the Tha food or the women they probably
have a combo too where you get the food
and the women they'll see it to you I'll
see like nerdy ass white boys mhm like
being pimps with like three six women
next to them like dude for 50 bucks
you're a player uh all you think is that
guy's cool yeah that gu that guy's full
of herpes that guy gets laid man that
guy's got the garia
$50 $50 for a lady boy it was crazy yeah
and lady boys look good too it's crazy I
was looking at them like dting my
sexuality like damn they look better
than me look at their bodies like oh I'm
just going to throw myself off the clip
with an
elephant so I come out on the newspaper
over there and I got the front cover
when I got the front cover I called my
mom I'm like am I
come say everybody get ready look good I
come back to LA in 4 days and we're
going to Paradise Co Malibu please do
not look like pisas and they were like
okay they picked me up and I came back
with the front cover of the [__] it was
called the brunch the Sunday brunch I
was like Mom I hope I make you proud I
felt like biggie Smiles every time my
face is up in the source I was like I'm
in the branch mom and Thailand she has
no idea what it says I don't know what
the [__] it says but I just know I'm in
the front cover middle spread and it's
all about my art and they they just
really liked my art and I was like damn
like and I just I honestly went to
Thailand just to eat do you guys like
Thai food [__] it I like it is pretty
damn good that was one of those things I
got late in life too me too I was such a
little [__] I still am a lot with when
it comes to like food I'm like H that
doesn't I don't want to pickled what you
know just like Dusty man I started off
with pad thae that's Po and then after
that man I started eating curries a
yellow curry went there yet in life
haven't went there yet and then mang
sticky rice and mango okay you know why
I went to Thailand I only went to
Thailand cuz I was in Japan and my homie
was like a four hours from here is
Thailand on a plane I saw I saw on
YouTube like you go up to this cart in
the middle of Bangkok and there's a
bunch of carts wooden carts with a big
pile of rice sticky sweet rice and a
bunch of mangoes and then they cut them
and they slice them and they serve you
and then they put the coconut cream on
top right so my dream was to go up to
that cart my little wet back Mexican
dream just to go up to that cart and be
like that [__] cart sounds good too
yeah and I was like that little wooden
car that was like nailed in by a little
Bangkok bed and I just wanted to be like
I want mango sticky rice and that was my
dream and that's why I went the whole
painting walls in the newspaper that
wasn't even in the story I didn't want
to be an artist I just wanted to be a
tort I just wanted to eat mango sticky
rice it was 25 cents every plate over
here you pay seven bucks [__] 20 was it
good though it was bomb dude I would
literally take like 10 bucks with me and
I will sit there and Order seven
different plates and like mango sticky
rice with taii tea and I would just eat
seven different plates with two desserts
and I will I will take 10 bucks to make
sure that I spent what do you spend over
here on a plate of food over here it's
like $10 for a plate of D food I'm like
let me let me keep it like that and I
would take it and I would just eat
everything I would take a bite of the
curry the tangon the the mango sticky
rice the freaking fried rice everything
dude the every it was delicious that sh
making me hungry it was delicious
chicken sa it was bomb you guys need to
go to Thailand now what what other place
have you eaten great food like that you
know what when I went to Mexico to to go
to the pyramids I actually set myself a
goal I was like I'm going to go to the
pyramids and get enlightened because
that week it was crazy that week glass
was breaking everywhere around me and
I'm not superstitious you know
Mexican I don't mom shut up I don't want
to hear it
yeah I'm like I don't want to hear it
Mom
Santo stop it I just want to paint with
spray cans so I go to Mexico and one of
my friends that's very spiritual she's
like how many glasses have broken this
week I'm like girl all my mom's glasses
all her thought it was Greek all her
princess house all her princess house
you know the mom Mexican moms love that
little glass thing that has the flower
designs on it it's really expensive the
crystal for nobody to
use when I was little I girl my mom
having a big ass chetta a big ass
Furniture piece in the middle full of
plates and cups and bowls like those
clear ones and you couldn't touch them
dude that was only for
guests so I end up in in Mexico uh I was
like let me go get enlightened and I
went to go eat and I go to Coan which is
where Freda Gallo is from I I am the fra
Gallo of today okay with my art so I go
to kakan and I'm eating there like just
Mexican food tamales people that are
walking by I'm like let me get that let
me get that like I am not you're picky
I'm not that picky I'm like [__] it If
I'm going to die at least it was from
somebody's little hand bad tamale will
ruin my day though I'll get it to Molly
I'll get it to mly and if there's like
not an appropriate amount of meat in it
I like that'll kill me if there's if
there you ever get a tam mly that's like
all Masa and there's like a little meat
and you're like what the hell dude like
how can you live at night man what are
you doing one strand of meat yeah
there's like and it's not you're like is
this me this is this like part of this
this burnt inner Tom M like what the
hell is this man you're the winner yeah
dude that's why I don't trust tamali
anything where I can't see the meat
inside I'm like he cheated you're 125 he
gave you 25 cents worth of a powdered
Masa from the Masa box that's crap man I
hate that dude I go to Mex Mo bro all
give you a mall the M I love M B I'm in
so I'm over there and I'm eating
everything and then I was like I'm going
to go pay and KOA I want we fre from and
it's like a really it's like Beverly
Hills they're like you can't paint it
everybody's telling me no I went and
painted a big giant like 50 foot by 30
foot wide it was a big doll like 60 feet
tall I was just like yes oh that's so
cool but when I was out there I was just
like the food like while I was there
painting people were driving buying
bicycles a tort with Tamal inside I was
like give it to me chor give it to me
tort with a Tamal do everything just I
love tamales so if I see tamales I'm
like come over here how much yeah damn
Tamal is good I grew up in Texas so it
was really weird I I gra a lot of tax
Maxs and stuff so whenever I you got to
put chili beans in chamali yeah when I
first dude when I first came to LA and I
was like I ordered an enchilada I was
like what what is this where's the meat
sauce and the uh where's my big quesso
chip you
know and I'm trying to tell them I'm
like can I have queso they're like no
he's queso I'm like no like the the
liquid and I look like such a fat ass no
I want the liquid cheese you know it
makes it all so in Texas somebody in
Houston Texas somebody told me we're
going to go get breakfast takitos and
I'm okay going be a lot of takito Pastor
and all that but all the takito were
with flow tortillas and I was like just
selling me small burritos yeah that's
the waterburger Taquito it's like it
yeah yeah all the taquitos in Texas are
with flour tortillas then then people
from Texas come to LA and you get
takitos and they're like the little
tortillas you got like man so that [__]
all small yeah what the hell man yeah
everything's all small little tacos and
stuff I'm like I want a big eat 10 of
them bro yeah eat 10 of them you know
what's funny somebody opened my eyes to
that logistic I was little and I was
like I [__] hate HomeTown Buffet cuz
when you go and you get the fish they
give you little fishes and my homie was
like yeah but you could grab the whole
tray I'm like that makes sense you just
eat a whole tray and it equals a big ass
fish it all make sense order more I had
this place ponchos growing up this is
big me you eat right you put a flag yeah
you put the flag up and oh my God I
loved it so much that was one of those
places they kind of had like smaller
portions but i' tell the guy and the
waiter the waiter would like recognize
me and sucked like oh big guy over here
over there that place I think you put a
flag and it put they bring more food
yeah they bring more food yeah we have a
friend in Ralphie May and he weighs like
450 PBS and he was telling me the story
about he went to the place called
ponchos and I said I bet the wait
raising the [__] surrender
flag yeah
yeah D you took over the
Alo I heard of of to places where they
charge like big big people for two like
oh you got to pay for two yeah Texas has
a lot of buffet been placees where they
charge skinny people they charge skinny
people like it's a all you can eat
buffet but if you leave food on your
plate they charge you for it does sushi
places do that a lot the Chinese SP oh
they're vicious with it they're hella
vicious all you can eat but you get one
napkin yeah you can ask for another but
you won't yeah man this lady over there
I don't know if you been to the dollar
Chinese restaurant right there on daily
Street on daily and Lincoln Heights
there's a dollar restaurant right there
I know where daily is right there you
get orange chicken that's red I have a
mirror off of like fig off a Broadway or
something like that Broadway I don't I
don't really know that lady wraps around
a fork and a napkin a two and a
Chopsticks and a soy sauce and one
napkin and that's all you get if you try
to ask for more the little look at you
like but you uh you have one plate you
need only one
por no I need 10 soy sauces to make your
food taste good lady oh people are crazy
in Thailand they were vicious with me
and I was like oh like when I order they
be like I was like all right I get it
like us Mexicans were're more hospitable
likea a little hug yeah
yeah yeah I I went to a tuon Arizona
recently and and when I went to go eat
my beans I love eating beans I was
painting a mural off of a for Avenue in
tuon I was doing two murals actually and
then I go eat beans cuz I love beans
with avocado I just want beans boiled
beans with avocado and the lady was like
can I give you a tour of my restaurant I
was like yeah she took me around the
restaurant and told me how her mom was a
gerera I was like damn this is nice over
here in La we don't got time for that
[__] hey we got to go you got to clear
the plate like you know there people in
line and you've been on that table for
20 minutes you got to go it's 10 minutes
per person like it it was just crazy I
was like they're so hospitable H yeah I
feel like I was in trouble here now lady
you see the restaurant in two in two
seconds here's the back here's the
front where's the bathroom bathroom hey
10 minutes liit eating stop talking
about your girlfriend I know man welcome
to Hero what's the place called in E
hero yeah I don't know the play with the
flas oh it's on the same street oh
there's a place it's next to mano
special but there's another restaurant
down the street across the street from
elementary school I have a I have a
right there it's a doll with big uh
petal eyelash petals sorry I'm telling
you man I've seen your paintings
everywhere cuz everywhere reading your
paintings there cuz I remember I
remember going to tayak after that and
and I got the big ass burrito and I
couldn't eat it and I was like wow this
is intense I it just a giant burrito and
if you're not big then even if you're
big you still can't chug that down it's
huge giant it's too much meat man they
put like a lot of pork inside with
guacamole and rice and beans and then
they it up with more pork and sauce on
top of it oh see that to me that's like
that gave me extra 10 tortillas and a
start you could start your own business
with one of those
burritos delivery taco delivery put them
up and and pack them and take them I'm
going to take it no when I'm a taco St
you know what's crazy when I went to
thailan I became a vegan not all I eat
is vegetables been like a year and a
half and all I want to eat is vegetables
I'm V too and and fish I I'll let I'll
let fish slide in small amounts but I
really enjoy vegetables whole grains
like uh oatmeal smoothies and my mom
thinks I'm a freak like whenever I go
paint a w or something or when I go to
my office to paint like my canvases I'm
literally eating oatmeal or drinking
smoothies or eating like protein shakes
my mom's
like I go to the family parties and
they're like K Sala you want K Sala with
the beans I'm like just give me beans
why they want to argue my family wants
to throw it down with me because I don't
want to eat meat oh you think you're
better than us now no I just don't want
to eat meat that's the first thing they
say you think you're better than us yeah
I would just being here don't want to
[__] everybody here vegan baby dusty
over here with his meat s pescarian
pescarian stop eating cows man I
probably ate like three you're not
Mexican I get that a lot oh they say
that you're not Mexican not EA i p a
vegan food up and then I put that it's
vegan you're not Mexican or they put
they tell me that I like they get pissed
off I you change you're not really
Mexican you forgot where you came from
but if you really want to go all the way
back we were the original atic warriors
were vegan we didn't have no [__]
cows to eat there was no cows here to to
make why people showed up with them I
hate that [__] when they tell you oh you
Chang and I'm sure you've heard it like
you Chang or you're not the same no more
don't forget where you come from I don't
forget but if I'm in a better place in
life I'm going keep running with that
like I remember where I came from and
that's why I'm where I'm at because that
[__] [__] made me not want to be
there so instead of telling me don't
forget how about you start forgetting
and start doing better and you'll be
right where I'm at and we'll be eating
vegan food together at stage in freaking
Echo
Park I don't know
yies or at uh Fior Fior oh my God we're
doing advertisement for them they better
give us a hookup remember our faces I
want that that strawberry cake oh that
strawberry cake that weighs 2 PBS oh if
that strawberry cake is like a like a
lemon poppy cake oh I'm going there
after this I had the cinnamon roll
yesterday I ate it this morning at Flor
yeah it's really good like I just feel
good eating healthy food like I'm a
straight wet back P off from E Mexican
watermalon I have no business being an
artist because my mom didn't know what
the hell I was doing when I became an
artist she was like what do you mean
you're going to be an artist you're
going to struggle you need to go work at
Chase I'm like I don't want to count
people's money I want to count my money
and she was like you need to go work at
McDonald's like what do you mean you
need to go to college I literally like
I'm I'm becoming successful now with my
art right people like my art and I love
that women love my art when I do an art
show people come to my art shows you
know and it feels good like people come
to my art show people come to your
comedy shows and you're like you're here
to see me you're here to listen to all
my dumb [__] I created this yeah it's
it's is your movement so when I started
being an artist my mom was like having a
heart attack like No And I was like Mom
I'm going to be an artist and I'm going
to figure it out and I'm going to just
rough it out on dollar menu so now like
now everybody trips out like oh you
Chang my family they're like oh you're
different no I'm the same I just don't
want to eat cows I used to eat off that
dollar menu too though yeah like
chickens all day you don't even know
where the chicken comes from you don't
even know if it's a chicken weenie or
what the hell is it you're just eating
that [__] with ketchup you know what I
did the other day at McDonald's must I
ordered at the drive-thru I ordered a I
ordered a chicken sandwich and the guy
was like you say double cheeseburger and
I'm like
yeah I don't care just give me something
to shove in my
mouth like don't even care anymore
man you just stopped caring after a
while but yeah cuz it's all like it's
like I'm at McDonald's man like just
give already you're already going to
have cholesterol anyway McDonald's yeah
like I I'll go to a papoa place I just
want veget vegetable I don't care if
just give me veins whatever just give it
to me just just don't give me the animal
that's good do you guys ever have
withdraw like you don't did you was it
tough for you like to switch or was it
an easy no cuz I was already hurting
from my [__] already I was kind of
easy see that's just part of life though
right I was a fat pig bro I I was I was
a fat pig that had no right trying to do
the Atkins diet you lost a lot of weight
man yeah how much weight you lost I was
300 now I'm 270 nice
265 I was 185 and nown yeah you're no no
180 180 hitting 180 and now I'm I'm I'm
at 150 so I lost 30 lbs I and how tall
are you 5'1 51 you couldn't tell my
boots were huge and my gut was bigger my
face it was all up here black people
were saying yeah I love your art yeah
yeah yeah yeah hey Mom hey what's up Mom
I want to buy your art first you got to
see your titty Stu
I got to see your titties before I
negative papey negative negative Don f
are like that man yeah man cting show
more
Nal no Dar
now yeah n call yourself a
lady at my house oh I've heard that like
hey you want to come and paint a Miro in
my in my room what the [__] am I going
to do in your room I'm not going to go
to your how about you buy a paint and
then you can hang it up in your room a
you're stuck up I don't want to go your
room brother what do they think's going
to happen like you're just going to be
all naked
pain I think they're going to like creep
up and be like real man so what's up
sand and I'll be like you have like
somebody walk up to you cuz guy who try
anything yeah my my lady is a big fan of
your art but he has no really no
girlfriend but that his way in oh they
see that and then the next time they
meet a we broke up yeah oh
damn kick it now a I never kick it look
one time I'm at this party I'm at Down
and Out in downtown and I'm dancing I
see this really T I'm TR like really
tall like skinny guys right so I see
this like really lightskinn like white
looking guy and I'm like yeah we're
dancing and finally he's just coming up
to me and he like looks down at me cuz
he was so tall and he's like hey I
really like your art and I was like I
just started dancing the other way and I
just walked away I was like damn like so
it wasn't really me you were checking
out it was like oh that's sest girl you
know damn see I'm like that opposite
like if someone I go to a chick and
they're like I like your comedy I'm like
I'm getting late
tonight my
set you want to come see me
rehearse yeah rehearse well I was
hanging out with his comedian one time
and um me and Gabriel were being funny
because we were funny at the comedy show
and this comedian they didn't they
didn't see his set they got there too
late this [__] went to his car
and brought his Tonight Show set and
made those chick play in their house
what what to prove that he's funny
that's hilarious man come on bro that is
[__] we we all have different levels of
psychon that's well that's what said
that psychon I should have thought about
that then but it took me five more years
to realize that I've taken guys to my
studio before like hey you want to come
to my studio yeah all right come to
apartment no my actual Studio where I P
they never get to go to my house they're
like hey so Su can I go to your house
hell's no I'll meet you in my studio
well why is it always in your studio
what do you mean that's where [__] goes
down
nothing goes down in my room my house
just me and my dog just sleep
[__] I sleep in my house you you
come see me in my studio I feel like a
big player I think I think being being
different does pull in you know the
people like I'm sure the girls well not
you guys you guys are married now but
I'm sure not you you're you're married
but like with me like there's nothing
like a girl with a spray can like I
guess guys are like oh and I'm like yeah
anything that's like really cool and
unique like that that's like like man
that's like dope especially cuz it's
like if someone anything that's out of
the norm and something that like you're
really good at it's like whoa that's
like really attractive right there she's
good at painting I'm like yeah I'm good
at painting I have a brain too cuz if it
were like someone like oh she's good at
counting money at Chase Bank it's not as
cool you know what I'm saying yeah I was
dating this mind it was awesome to she
opened her mouth at
home I'm going to pain you you're good
at comedy we're all good at something so
even if we're ugly it makes us 10 times
more sex that's what we're here yeah
pretty much and our little dwelling I
remember man having stay with beautiful
what like it's happen all the time but
I'm married to a beautiful woman now but
the first time I had sex with a
beautiful woman that that shouldn't that
should I have [__] you yes I was
trying to convince myself nah man it Ain
for you dog I wasn't ready in the house
already man this thing for you bro yeah
comedy changes everything but then all
sudden know this just me man and then
you turn into an [__] you're like you
know what yeah I'm going to bang every
chick out there you laughed her way into
the
bed it's okay that my stomach's on top
of her butt okay she likes this this a
funny story for her later you know I'm
going to tell her my friend she probably
going to tell I'm pretty sure the only
person that's going to talk about this
later is
me she doesn't want to even think she
was with you delete all my pictures
please block me tell no one of this oh
straight up like it it makes it makes
you guys it makes us more attractive cuz
we have a skill not everyone can be
funny you know like not everyone can be
funny not everybody can be funny man I
hung on with people who are not funny
serious sad like hanging out with Hank
Hill bro oh yeah but of no personality
no personality bro like that guy Michael
Scott from the office like not funny
yeah it's sad when people try it bro and
it's sad when those people try to do
standup
comedy have there been called comedians
that are now funny you're like yeah
Ernie G yeah I don't know no not a
comedian but it's horrible cuz he ooh
it's like um this person just had a
horrible set and we're over there trying
to pick up on chicks and he's standing
there too man it's like why is my friend
here with no head standing
here it's uncomfortable huh dude you
bomb just get away from us yeah bro you
smell yeah bro come on smell [__] listen
we get him next time it's horrible man I
don't know if you ever happened to you
man where you're hanging around with an
artist that hav't sold [__] and you sold
everything you're killing it and this
person trying to hang out with you like
maybe they'll buy our pointings maybe
they'll buy two for one I I been in AR
show where like I fell out and then
there's other artist and they're just
staring at me and I'm like oh [__] like
I feel bad like hey I'm sorry like I
have the crowd I'm not like look at me
like people just automatically I'm sorry
[__] but I brought air
fresheners yeah with $500 paintings My
milkshake brings all the girls to the
yard like I don't know people just come
my way and I'm like Dam like one time I
went to an artist AR show I went to go
see the guy's art and then boom there's
a crowd like s and I'm like hey hey
we're not here for me we're here for him
can you guys get away from me and
they're like no I to take it to the
alley I was like come on let's go to the
alley then and then I signed everybody's
books but I felt so bad he when he
walked in I was like oh man like I'm
here for you bro but they're here for
you and me now that happens to me all
the time I'll be at the store and Chris
Rock will be on stage I'm like I'm just
dusy bar I was in Gotham chill out just
get away from me people please I'm a
human being fine I'll show you my
belly qu my
tip yeah man what else what else people
you anything coming up you want to tell
our our listeners go watch you go check
you out Instagram everything I got a
slogan called put your feelings in a box
that's pretty much like what we do every
day when you wake up and whatever you're
feeling you just put it away and you're
like I got to come and get on this
podcast you know so like it's pretty
much like and it's been getting a lot of
girls through a lot of my viewers they
like Sam I feel you like every day like
about 30,000 girls watch me which maybe
it's not a lot but to me it's a lot
30,000 girls on my Snapchat that's
60,000 eyes blinking watching me every
day so every day I wake up and I'm like
What's Up bches put your feelings in a
box and they're like and then I get like
s my feelings are in a box thank you so
much like just thinking about that helps
me through my day so I created my new
doll her name is boxy and it's like a
girl with bug teed butching big frizzy
hair probably orange hair no boobs hella
long and she holds a box and in the box
there little hearts coming out so she
puts her feelings in a box so I'm going
to have an R show in the next two months
and then yesterday at night I bought a
trip to EA oh [__] I know it's crazy my
dream is to go to iisa so I bought a
trip to iisa for 1,6
last night was the Y yeah so
I'm I'm going to IA like none of my
Chola gangster like e home girls they
been between be and wither no yeah okay
but they don't care like nobody from
like my friends are like all makeup
artist like oh hey girl take a photo of
me for my Instagram like none of them
care about and I was like you know what
it's either now or never and one of my
friends is a DJ and he's like hey I'm
going to IA I'm like you can I tag along
he's like if you want I'm like dude got
it and he's like you're really going I'm
like I'm coming to ibisa I need to go
and paint a doll in iisa somewhere in
iisa and it needs to be a doll holding a
little heart pill and it has to say I
took a pill in IA you know like that one
song I'm going to IA you guys hopefully
I find like this rich like Middle
Eastern guy over
there be 65 but he'll be there that's
fine I will take I will look at his
young pictures when he's there behind
you you were beautiful when you served n
H I'm just going to imagine this photo
might be in black and white it might
have been drawn but [__]
it artist Essence I have a good
imagination so if the essence of what he
want was I'll pain an eyelash on him
yeah so he I'm going to EA so I'm like
hella hella pumped that's good man I'm
going on a starvation diet so I look
bomb that's the way to do it man do your
art travel eat a lot of good food man
and be happy and laugh and love him and
like don't think about like negativity
there's no there's negativity in every
single aspect of of your business or of
your life like put him in a box put them
in a box and keep going and U let's see
what's next uh I'm gonna I'm going to IA
so I'm looking for a boyfriend and I'm
releasing my new doll in a week boxy so
that's pretty exciting and then there's
something else going on pretty soon I
just can't think about it oh I'm going
to be on TV I'm going to be on La TV
next week La TV yeah la TV I'm going be
on LA TV just running around talking so
I'm excited thank you guys that's a
social media your social media Instagram
San Warner s n d o n e r s I have a lisp
and thankfully my name is
sand s a n d sand one o n e r that's my
Instagram and Facebook and uh Twitter
and my website is sand.com and you can
know you can learn all about my dolls on
my website my dolls are really cute and
they all have a personality smooth
Hustler is one captain ber muda let me
know what let me know what your
daughter's like I'll give you guys some
stuff for your daughter some little
pillows and stuff I have a daughter
named Tuesday really you're lying yeah
oh well we have a I'm sure I got a doll
for her that she'll like I'll give her a
pillow so she could have that's cuz you
have stuff like there for people who
can't afford to buy one of your
paintings because one cuz man imagine
all that money van go and Picasso would
have made oh my God yeah tell you I
don't have a I don't have a van go but I
have a van go
CH van go imagine that you had a [__]
merch from Picasso oh that'd be great
man I would have to lie about
it that's pretty much why I did a
merchandise cuz I was like not everyone
can do you know thousands but you could
do 10 bucks for an air freshener and
it's still not 10 it's 10 bucks you know
you get little treats for a dollar but
this is not little treats this is s one
art so yeah I'm I'm I'm hyped about my
my life and my art and it's going to get
big bigger bigger than it is right now
big bad East Lo in the house that's
right
people all right people San Diego July
25th one night only at hum free by the
July
15th what did I say 25th all right we're
going to cut that unless you people
watching it live on YouTube you heard it
you heard it all wrong San Diego July 15
one night only at Humphries by the bay
Arlington Virginia Washington DC area
July 29 and 30 at Arlington draft House
West Palm Beach Florida August 4th
through the 7th at The Improv and we
have free a few free tickets for you to
give away just email me at fans
felipesworld dcom for West Palm Beach
only and say what's up fool give me
those tickets Hermosa Beach California
August 10 one night only I'm headlining
that [__] with I don't we don't know
the comedians yet comedy magic club
comedy magic club I'll be headlighting
there Marcel and Fred ster FR Fred
staller and Marcel Chicago I met Joe's
on weed Street august 19 and 204 shows
they will sell out so get yours early at
Mickey comedy Mikey comedy.com or at
joeb bar.com see all the dates at
philppe world.com also on my web page
philppe world.com just a little window
was the um Amazon window that you could
go buy and Shop stuff through there hey
if you want to buy by sand sand owners
sand owner her penties go to Philipp
world.com and then go to the Amazon page
and then look for San one and go buy all
her stuff go straight to her web page
Dustin what's you going on besides um
more hair H damn bro you got you turn it
to The Wolf Man during the show bro
quick man right no hair dude I don't
know what happened man damn dude yeah
how long was this podcast jeez man the
Str I started rubbing your hair and
started right what you got here you had
less hair looking him some of it's
coming out from my back the collar right
now full moon yeah dude um I've been uh
I'm working on a couple of movies right
now they're not going to come out for
forever though so uh but uh got some
Road gigs coming up in Dallas all at
Dustin aara.com going to Charleston and
um yeah just a few other places working
with you man yes that's fun we working
on the show Man Dustin bar and I before
we leave we're actually going to pitch a
show next week this week next week to
another local network conratulations
thank you we've been talking to um
Peter Mara Peter maretta of course he
was the creator of Wither of Waverly and
some other shows and he worked on a
cristella show and Bobby Bowman Bobby
Bowman he worked on um My Name is Earl
King of the Hill and it's always sun in
Philadelphia so we'll see what happens
if they like our show or not but we'll
still be here on the what's up F podcast
thank you very much to San Juan for
being our lovely guest and teaching us
about art and letting us know that you
can be a feminist even with your clothes
on or your clothes off it all depends on
the idea behind it it's your skill that
matters it's not your body yes like
yours phip thank you very
much we we could do this people what's
up food podcast what up hell yeah
picture
time okay I'm